- We're... concerned.
The Soviets might be trying to
introduce a new weapon.
- We let this go...
...it would set
a dangerous precedent.
- Welcome to NASA.
You are, as of this moment,
officially astronaut candidates.
- Some day people will
write the history of this time.
- This is Jamestown actual.
Ten seconds... mark.
- They will say that during
the coldest depths of the Cold War,
(alarm chirps)
- America inspired the world.
♪ Sweet dreams are made of this ♪
- I give you Pathfinder.
It's three times as powerful
as our current shuttles.
- I'm tired of talking about
the good ol' days.
(laughs)
- Don't y'all miss it?
♪ Some of them want to use you ♪
- With this weapon, they could
drop munitions on any point on Earth.
♪ Some of them want to be... ♪
- The President wants you to put
together a new mission.
- I shouldn't go.
- You don't think I notice the look
in your eyes at every launch?
- Hoorah.
♪ Sweet dreams are made of this ♪
- I have here the rules of engagement
for use of force on the Moon.
♪ Travel the world and... ♪
- That's steps away from nuclear war.
- Target lock.
- Once we do this thing,
there's no going back.
(alarm blaring)
- This program...
...has the power
to change the world.
- You need to remind them of Apollo 11.
- We came in peace for all mankind
- Ready to fire.
- We need to live up to that.